bien venir c'est que de la télé vous
venez nous parler de votre livre on ne
choisit pas qu'ils ont m
c'est votre autobiographie vous y
raconter qu'à l'âge de 21 ans alors que
vous êtes en couple avec un jeune homme
vous est alors je cite entre guillemets
avec chrétienne et bourgeoise 1 ce sont
ses propres termes
vous rencontrez aurore d'ailleurs je
crois même que c'est dans ces studios
dans la vidéo et en dix ans il est fou
et magnifique royal
justement vous dites et la bam coup de
foudre
oui oui en plus elle d'abord qui qui m'a
couru un peu après pendant pendant un
certain temps et puis petit à petit
voilà je me suis rendu compte que la
mauricie moi aussi je tombais
complètement amoureuse de cet homme de
saddam est justement alors pourquoi et
pour qui avez vous envie d'écrire ce
livre
alors j'ai eu envie d'écrire mon
parcours tout simplement parce que
pendant ces dix dernières années j'ai
manqué cruellement de repères je faisais
des recherches sur internet je cherchais
des histoires un peu semblable à la
mienne et je trouvais personnes à qui
mme identifiés pour trouver des réponses
et puis un jour je me suis dit ben voilà
il s'est passé dix ans si moi je partage
mon histoire et si ça peut aider des
gens alors je le fais voilà il y en a
plein qui sont en recherche et si ça
peut aider voilà avec plaisir parce que
justement vous vous sentiez un peu isolé
voir les beaux coups isolés parce que
avec une famille pratiquante
parce qu'avec un milieu social
prédéfinis avec un chemin qui vous
étaient tracées et donc vous aviez le
sentiment d'être sortie du chemin et il
n'y avait dans la littérature
aucune personne similaire entre
guillemets à laquelle vous auriez pu
vous identifier oui c'est ça je pense
que mon parcours est un peu atypique
mais je suis pas la seule je le sais ne
suis pas la seule mais que que l'on ne
parle pas de tous ces couples là on dans
notre milieu on nous demande de nous on
dit voilà on vous en parlait beaucoup
dans le livre que non le crès il ya
beaucoup de secrets il ya beaucoup de
familles qui vivent avec des secrets
comme cela et puis c'est pas normal
voilà donc un moment il faut enfoncer
les portes faut bien quelqu'un il ya
donc j'y vais à retrousser les manches
et la niveau puisque permis classique
hall gill
ils ont énormément apprécié votre libre
et ils ont lu avec beaucoup d'intérêt
on va commencer par joe nick et des
questions à vous poser oui lorsque vous
êtes rencontre rendue compte de votre
amour pour aurore qu'est-ce qui a été le
plus dur à surmonter le regard des
autres votre éducation ou la possible
réaction d'autres familles la réaction
de la famille dont j'avais évidemment
très peur mais même moi mon regard par
rapport à moi-même j'ai vu que je
dessinais un portrait parfait de ma vie
future que j'imaginais avec un mari
trois enfants à la campagne etc
je pense qu'une fois que que soit on a
réussi à faire le deuil finalement de
cette image parfaite qu'on avait dessiné
quant à soi on est on est en phase avec
soi-même finalement la suite ça roule
dire que moi j'étais j'étais sûr de ce
que je faisais je me sentais bien dans
mes baskets et c'est ça qui m'a aidée à
surmonter après tout le reste avec pas
la facilité avec moi ma main vous et
vous avez quand même beaucoup de courage
et notamment vous parlez de votre
famille vous êtes allé quand marié et
vous parliez non dits vous revenez à la
charge pour essayer de sortir les vers
du nez pour essayer de d'avoir un vrai
dialogue et pas d'être dans une sorte
d'entre deux oui je suppose que c'est
toi je ne supporte pas les non dits je
supporte que je suis très impatiente et
je pense que si si j'avais rien fait les
choses n'auraient peut-être pas pas
bougé parfois j'ai été trop impatiente
et peut-être que si j'avais été sa plus
belle somme dans certains moments les
choses seraient arrivés plus
naturellement
mais effectivement je me suis dit si moi
j'y vais pas il se passera rien il
restera dans ses mots quand vous dites
parfois avec un peu trop d'impatience
vous avez le sentiment vous parfois de
les brusquer eux
oui je les ai brusquer oui oui je pense
que parfois comme dans plein de crise de
famille les mots dépassent les pensées
et je sais que ça a été difficile pour
eux parce qu'on ne naît pas tous avec le
même bagage eux arrivent avec avec une
éducation avec des valeurs chrétiennes
etc etc c'est difficile ce que je leur
demandais et c'était aussi à moi de
comprendre qu'ils peuvent pas aller
aussi vite que moi je suis amoureuse
donc je me laisse porter mais pour eux
c'est pas pareil pour autant vous ne
vouliez pas non plus mettre un nom sur
l'amour que vous portiez vous ne vous ne
vous sentiez pas vous ne vous disiez pas
homosexuel non je me dis toujours pas
homosexuel je considère que que qu'on
tombe amoureux en tout cas c'est mon cas
je suis tombée amoureuse un homme puis
je suis tombée amoureuse d'une femme et
on a beaucoup posé la question on a
beaucoup interrogé est-ce que du coup tu
aimes les femmes et tu as aimé que des
femmes où on voit là et j'ai fait une
thérapie
vraiment je me suis bon bah si les gens
se posent la question
et puis c'était un peu d'eux m'a dit un
jour mais si vous n'avez pas besoin de
vous mettre dans une case je ne
cherchais pas à le faire pour répondre
aux besoins des autres vous êtes vous
c'est tout et j'ai arrêté ce jour là
nous poser la question bien sûr
caroline alors qu'ils étaient en passion
de votre nuque a également un besoin
d'en parler encore dans la loge tout à
l'heure à sion syllabes semer mais c'est
hyper jolie et je voulais même pas
arriver à la fin parce qu'en fait je je
crois que je voulais pas savoir olalala
saint avold de ne le dis pas pour le
tester au que je devais rien évidemment
j'ai mille questions à vous poser j'ai
dû en sélectionner une en 2012
manif pour tous et là vous vous coupez
de votre religion catholique ouest à
pourquoi est ce que ses revenus depuis
alors que vous êtes issu d'une famille
ouais pratiquant m catholique que vous
même vous vous dites je ne je ne renie
pas la religion catholique je sens que
je me considère encore comme croyant je
suis croyant autant il ya une fracture
la wii la paire des manifs pour tout ça
est extrêmement violente pour moi est
plein de milliers de personnes
malheureusement parce que d'un coup j'ai
allumé la télévision et puis je voyais
dans ces manifs des gens qui me
ressemblaient des gens qui ces parties
de même style de famille que moi et se
sentir rejeté par son propre ni par ce
qui nous a forgé ce qu on a admiré
enfants c'est très difficile d'un conte
11 mai ce que je suis en train de faire
une bêtise c'est ce que et c'était
c'était vraiment douloureux et l'église
faisait partie intégrante de ma vie
j'allais à l'église
quasiment tous les dimanches et puis une
fois je vais à la messe je reçois un
tract à la sortie de l'église me
proposant d'aller à la manif pour tous
puis notre melli un prêtre fait une
allusion et puis une autre une autre est
un moment je me suis dit juste il faut
chaud en phase avec moi-même c'est à
dire que je peux pas accepter sans et
humiliant et et gentiment de faire un
double jeu au près 10 et sa voix là et
j'ai pris conscience aussi je suis
devenu plus adulte dans ma relation avec
l'église
j'ai pris conscience que c'est une
institution dirigée par des hommes donc
comme n'importe quelle institution
dirigée par des hommes il ya ce qu'il ya
de meilleur et ce qui est le moins bon
et j'ai pris mes distances à ce moment
là
aujourd'hui je suis beaucoup moins
pratiquante mais ma foi elle est intacte
j'arrive vraiment la dissocier en fait
de mon rapport à l'église pour autant
voilà aujourd'hui vous continuez à dire
je suis croyante oui oui on est d'accord
jean michel a également une question un
mois je me suis posé la question de
savoir si vous pouviez nous suggérer
quelque chose pour un jeune homme ou une
jeune femme qui va se poser des
questions sur sa sexualité qu'est ce que
vous allez lui dire qu'est ce que vous
allez lui donner comme conseil qui peut
être comme vous alors peut être pas
forcément issus du même milieu bruit
effectivement à chaque fois peut-être
peut se dire ma famille risque de de
penser que je ne suis pas comme il faut
de penser que je sors du chemin tout
tracé de et le peur de ce rejet des
siens qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait le je
pense que déjà il faut il faut parler
c'est à dire rester dans ce doute
continue de dire oui mais s'ils
réagissent mal non un moment déjà il
faut y aller 1 parce que parfois on peut
avoir des bonnes surprises
moi j'ai finalement eu de bonnes
surprises mes parents ont accepté cette
situation je pensais pas que c'était
possible à ce moment là donc il faut y
aller déjà il faut aller dans le
dialogue n'a jamais lâché et surtout ne
pas accepter de vivre dans le mensonge
on m'a souvent parlé non choix de vie
ton choix de vie ton choix 10 n'ai pas
choisi d'aimer une femme
par contre je choisis tous les matins en
me levant d'être à la bonne place avec
la personne que j'aime et d'être libre
tout simplement et c'est ça il faut un
moment se dire la vie peut être courte
il faut essayer la passer avec les
bonnes personnes dont cause et vous dis
fayard oser oser on va juste terminé
avec j'espère une bonne nouvelle est ce
que vous avez renoué les ponts avec la
votre famille est ce que vous avez pu
tout vous dire oui oui même ma famille
aujourd'hui accepte la situation
ça leur a pris du temps et c'est normal
donc oui aujourd'hui aujourd'hui tout va
bien on est mariés
est heureuse avec aurore j'avais envie
de terminer quand même
[Applaudissements]
on se dise j'espère garder et voilà